In the US, US President Donald Trump...
...announced a partial travel ban on European countries in a rare Oval Office speech.
Trade will still continue with the restricted countries.
The European Union stated disappointment with the United States for imposing a travel ban on Europe...
...without first consulting with them.
They also rebuked Trump's criticism of their handling of the coronavirus pandemic.
In the US, the country's stocks plummeted after the president's travel ban announcement Wednesday.
The New York Stock Exchange experienced a 15-minute halt in trading on Thursday.
In Europe, European Central Bank President Christine Lagarde...
...revealed a new plan to help the struggling European economy during the coronavirus pandemic.
Finally from India, New Delhi ordered schools, colleges and movie theaters to close...
...in an effort to contain the spread of the coronavirus.
The number of cases in the country has now risen to 73.